the problem is the first the first movie
nobody knew that scene was going to be
iconic in this one we were like we knew
this thing was coming we knew the day
where all everybody's there were guys
eating protein paste it was it was bad
like you came out with the bands too oh
the resistance on the beach yeah what
else was there there's some footage out
there that's Monica to show you the
footage of all of us just going crazy
she's just like oh my gosh boys I'm glad
we're doing this as a film because I
think the fans will uh we'll enjoy that
that we did that's one of the first
things people have asked me if you're a
you know is there a volleyball scene I
heard your friends are pissed that
you're in this movie they're so jealous
that's getting some legs to it I did say
that but it is I just think they're
they're just hoping that they're able to
watch this movie that they want to watch
so bad and that not be thrown off that
uh you know that their buddy is is in it
we've all been working out we're running
we're dieting everyone feels great
everyone looks good uh originally when
we go to shoot the scene there's going
to be a shirts and skins team everyone
loses it everyone's like no I've been
working way too hard like there's no way
I can be shirts like that's no he should
be shirts absolutely not there was only
one shirt actually on that day
yeah one guy almost cried Joe finally
folds and he's like fine if you guys all
want to be skins be skins whatever so we
we shoot the scene we all feel great
it's a beautiful San Diego day it's like
the perfect golden Sunset behind us it's
absolutely beautiful on the beach miles
brings like a pack of beers we all sit
around and talk for a little bit that
night we decide to go out to a spot here
in downtown uh we order pizza Wings
beers everybody's celebrating like we
just had such a tater tots yeah
everybody's celebrating because this we
worked so hard for this scene the next
day Tommy Harper comes to set and he
tells us we're gonna have to reshoot
that again in like a week or two there
was just some stuff that didn't work in
there so we're gonna have to redo that
and everyone was like I can't do this
for another two weeks please don't make
me go back to this I don't want to do
this there's a lot of oil though there
was Vaseline there was grapeseed oil
there was coconut oil avocado oil
glycerin water chapstick
sunflower seed oil this is no joke there
everyone had everyone had was lathered
in like at least two or three of these
things at a time doing push-ups doing
push-ups like running in the water just
trying to get wet so it looks like sweat
was Dripping on us it was avocado oil
got me you know it's a high sheet oil
you know what I mean